If you've got a Bible with you, I invite you to turn with me to Exodus chapter 24.
Exodus 24, we've been walking through that book together.
And as we come to this chapter, we'll see that worship is a major theme in it.
In verse two, we find God issuing a call to worship.
Then we have a kind of worship service that should lead to a life of worship,
where worship is being expressed through the whole of life as God's people follow Him in every area.
And that theme is going to continue on through the book.
So next week, we're going to see the problem of idolatry is going to come up.
And then after that, we're going to be looking at the tabernacle together in its constructions.
We'll see that theme of worship continuing on.
But as we look at this chapter, we're confronted with an important question that I want us to
wrestle with, and it's, how can a sinful people draw near to God in worship?
How can sinful people draw near to Him in worship?
So let's read Exodus chapter 24, verses one to 11.
It's there in your worship guides as well, if you need to look at it there.
Then he said to Moses, come up to the Lord, you and Aaron and Nadab and Abihu and 70 of the elders
of Israel and worship from afar. Moses alone shall come near to the Lord,
but the others shall not come near Him and the people shall not come up with Him.
Moses came and told the people all the words of the Lord and all the rules
and all the people answered with one voice and said,
all the words that the Lord has spoken, we will do.
And Moses wrote down all the words of the Lord.
He rose early in the morning and built an altar at the foot of the mountain
and 12 pillars according to the 12 tribes of Israel.
And he sent young men of the people of Israel.
He offered burnt offerings and sacrificed peace offerings of oxen to the Lord.
And Moses took half of the blood and put it in basins and half of the blood he threw against the altar.
Then he took the book of the Covenant and read it in the hearing of the people.
And they said, all that the Lord has spoken, we will do and we will be obedient.
And Moses took the blood and threw it on the altar and said,
behold the blood of the Covenant that the Lord has made with you in accordance with all these words.
Then Moses and Aaron, Nadab and Abihu and 70 of the elders of Israel went up
and they saw the God of Israel. There was under his feet as it were a pavement of sapphire stone
like the very heaven for clearness. And he did not lay his hand on the chief men of the people
of Israel. They beheld God and ate and drank. This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
So Lord, now as we come to your word, I pray that you would open our eyes that we might behold
wondrous things there. Lord, by your spirit would you open our eyes to see more of Jesus.
You pray all this in his name. Amen. Amen. Well, I've never seen the movie Snakes on a plane,
but I have flown with toddlers. So I think I get the gist of what that movie is about.
Kids are wonderful, but they can obviously be a challenge as well. One time we were on an
international trip and we got to our third flight of the day. It was our last one and we
no doubt looked exhausted as we're coming onto the plane. And the pilot came out of the cockpit
and he saw us, I guess, struggling. And he said, hey kids, how are you doing? He said, Mom and
Dad, what would you think about them coming with me and my co-pilot in here to see where
we fly this plane? And we said, absolutely. So he very kindly took them in there as we kind of
made our way through first class. We didn't stop there and then continued on to economy and put
our bags away. And he essentially looked after the kids while we got ourselves situated there.
If we were to try the same thing in the flight, just kind of barge through economy in the first
class up to the same place that our kids were at earlier, we would quickly find out who
the air marshal was. Like there's no way you're going to break through all of that to get access
to where the pilot is. Well, next is 24. God invites his people to draw near to him
in worship. They're invited, but even so there are graduating levels of access. In other words,
you can't just decide I'm going to move from economy to business class up to where the
cockpit is. There's these graduating levels of access when it came to the presence of
God. You've got the as you read, you see the ordinary Israelites at the foot of the mountain.
And so they were to worship God from the foot of the mountain. But then Moses, 70 elders and other
leaders go up into the presence of God. But then later at the end of the chapter, you see
Moses and Joshua being called to go further up into the presence of God. And then finally
Moses enters the cloud where God's glory is dwelling. And he's even closer to the Lord. You see that
difference there in all the way back in verse two of chapter 24 that Moses alone comes near,
but the others are further off. This pattern of graduated access to the Lord is going to
continue on in the construction of the tabernacle, which we're going to look at in a couple of
weeks. It's just like Mount Sinai. You've got the courtyard was that kind of outer part of the
tabernacle. That's where the people of Israel could be. But then that was separated from the
holy place, which is where only the priests could go. And then you then have the holy of
Holies, that most holy place where only the high priest could enter. He would enter there on the
day of atonement, graduated access. So one of the things that this shows us that this
teaches us is the need for a mediator. So a mediator is a go between who stands between God
and man. And this is the role that Moses is fulfilling here within the life of God's people here at this
mountain, this in between space between heaven and earth. He's standing up there. And that role
is going to continue that in between role that mediatorial role is going to continue
in the priesthood. So how can sinful people draw near and worship a holy God? Well, the answer that
we're seeing here is through a mediator. Well, Moses role as a mediator and then the mediators that
are then going to follow are ultimately pointing to a greater mediator who was yet to come.
And that mediator is Jesus Christ. And so today we confess with the Apostle Paul as he did in
1 Timothy chapter 2 and verse 5, there is one God and one mediator between God and man,
the man Christ Jesus. He is the one who connects heaven and earth as it were. And he is a better
mediator than what we see here. So what makes Christ a better mediator? Well, two things. That's
what we're going to look at here as we look at this chapter. First of all, Christ is a better
mediator because of the covenant he established. So what are we reading about next is 24. We have
in front of us here what you might call a covenant confirmation ceremony. So to understand
what's going on here, we just need to first of all understand what a covenant is. So what is a
covenant? But most simply, a covenant is an agreement between people, right? It's an agreement
they enter into. The most common example of a covenant relationship, both in Scripture and
in modern day really as well, is the covenant of marriage. That's a covenant we're all familiar with.
So in marriage you have what you might call a binding, living relationship with mutual blessings
and mutual obligations as well. And this is how Lick and Duncan helpfully defines a divine
covenant. So listen to what he says about what a divine covenant is. In other words,
a covenant between God and people. He says a divine covenant is a God initiated, binding,
living relationship with blessings and obligations. So once again, marriage is used to illustrate the
covenantal relationship that God has with his people and a marriage has a marriage ceremony
that goes along with that where vows are being made. And so we've got that kind of
covenant ceremony happening here in this chapter. That is what is going on. So what are the elements
of this covenant ceremony here at Sinai? Well, there's two major elements. You've got the
Book of the Covenant and you've got the blood of the Covenant. So the Book of the Covenant.
So God's word is being spoken to people through his servant Moses. So yes, as a mediator,
he's representing the people before God. He's also representing the Lord before the people as he's
speaking the words of God. So notice how central his word is in this covenant service here. So
verse three, Moses tells the people the words that the Lord has spoken. So we were looking at
10 commandments in chapter 20, but you didn't have further commandments that are given
to Moses to speak to the people. And so Moses is now telling people these words.
So he's telling them this is what the relationship is going to look like with the Lord as we follow
him together. In the second half of verse three after Moses has told them the words, the people
respond to the words that commit themselves to keep his word. That kind of pattern is then
repeated. Once again, you get to verse four. Moses writes down the word of the Lord, all the
words of the Lord it says. And by the way, don't miss the significance of that happening.
The word of God is here written down. I heard a word for the first time this week getting ready
for this. It was inscripturated. That's a great word. So here, what is a spoken word, God speaking
his word is now put into Scripture form, this written form for his people. Here it's called
the book of the covenant, the words of the Lord that are written down. So this is how we
have it today. The word of God has been written down for us. So these words are spelling out the
terms of what this covenant relationship is to look like and they agreed to them. They're willing
to submit to Yahweh as their Lord and Savior. They're confessing their faith in him here and
they're committing themselves to him. Let me just draw something, draw attention to something.
Just the fact that the word of God is central to the worship of God. And that's not just
the case here at this covenant ceremony or throughout the Old Testament. It's the case today. The word of
God is central to the worship of God. We do not worship a God of our own imagination. Rather,
we worship the God who has made himself known to us. Whereas he made himself known to us
in his word and his written word. And as we worship the Lord, both in our gatherings here
together, but also as we scatter and live the lives that were called to live, we worship
the Lord in the ways that he has told us to worship him. He tells us who he is and how we are to
respond. And that's found in the word. So that's why the word must be central in our worship.
So 1 Timothy chapter 4 and verse 13 in the New Testament says this. This is Paul writing to
Timothy. He says, until I come, devote yourself to the public reading of Scripture, to exhortation
and to teaching. So devote yourself to those things. So this is why the word of God is
central and must remain central to all that we do here at Trinity Fellowship. This is why when we
gather, we read the word. We pray the word. We sing the word. We preach the word. We respond to
the word. Both in our words and hopefully in our hearts and lives as well. Of course,
as we think about that, responding to the word is something we all fall short of. We all fall short
of living by the book, living out the terms of what this covenant relationship is supposed to look like.
You know, we've seen the sinful nature of the Israelites up to this point as they've made
their way through the wilderness. And only a few days later, we're going to see themselves,
them giving themselves over to idolatry in awful ways. That's why the next part is so crucial.
You've got the book of the covenant, but you also have the blood of the covenant is part of this
covenant ceremony. You see, if worship is going to be acceptable before the Lord, then the sin
of his worshipers must be atoned for. So how is their sin atoned for here?
It's through the sacrifices that are made on their behalf. So there in verse four, you've
got Moses building an altar where sacrifices are going to be made. At the same time, he makes
12 pillars each representing one of the tribes of Israel. So all of God's people are going to be
included in what is happening through the sacrifices that are made. Verse five, the sacrifices are
made. Verse six, the sacrifices are then applied. So Moses applies the blood of the sacrifices
in different places. He applies it to the altar where the sacrifices are made,
but he also fills basins with blood from the sacrifices. This is graphic what goes on here,
but it's what it says. He then takes the blood and he's putting it on the people. He's sprinkling
on the people. So they're now covered by the blood of the sacrifice. So what is going on here?
What the very least, there is a connection between the sacrifices that are offered on the
altar and the cleansing of the people. There's a connection between the two.
This is something we've seen earlier in Exodus. Remember the Passover?
When did God, what houses did God pass over? He passed over the houses when he saw the blood
that had been applied to the houses. His judgment passed over when the blood of the
sacrifice was applied to them. So a substitutionary sacrifice was needed to enable sinful people
to be in this covenant relationship with the Holy God. The sins are forgiven because the blood is
applied. As it says in Hebrews 9-22, without the shedding of blood, there is no forgiveness of sins.
So year after year, for generations to come, sacrifices are then offered as a covering
for the sins of the people. And these sacrifices temporarily covered their sins,
but they could not ultimately take away the sins of the people. So how are their sins actually going
to be taken away? It's because of what these sacrifices pointed to. They pointed to a greater
sacrifice that was yet to come, and that was a sacrifice that Christ was going to make when
he established this new and better covenant that he came to bring. You see, Christ established
a new covenant by shedding his blood that we might be cleansed and brought into a living,
eternal relationship with God. He is the sacrifice. He gave himself. You read about this in Hebrews 9 and
10. We see there that the sacrifices we see offered here in the Old Testament and throughout it,
we're pointing to the greater sacrifice of Jesus. So here what it says in Hebrews 10,
verses 11 and 12. It says, In every priest stands at his service, offering repeatedly the same
sacrifices, which can never take away sins. But when Christ had offered for all time a single
sacrifice for sins, he sat down at the right hand of God. So Jesus wasn't another symbolic sacrifice
offered up to God for the sins of the people. No, the blood that he shed on the cross was the
very blood of God made flesh in the person of his son, Jesus. The priest offered sacrifices
continually. But Christ, our great high priest, God's perfect representative, offered his life
as a once and for all sacrifice for sins. When he died, he says, It is finished.
There are no more sacrifices offered for sin because he has offered the once and for all
atoning sacrifice. And the blood that Jesus shed is applied to everyone who repents of their sin
and puts their faith in him. And when his blood is applied, God's judgment passes over.
So 1 Peter chapter one and verse two draws on the same exact kind of language we see here at
this ceremony. There it describes Christians as being those who have been sprinkled with the
blood of Christ. So if you've ever been reading that and wondering, it wasn't mean to be
sprinkled with his blood. This is what it's referring back to here. His blood is applied to all those
who put their faith in him because his blood is shed. We can know that we are cleansed, forgiven,
and welcomed into this relationship with God. And even when we commit ourselves to obeying him,
it is because his blood has already been shed on our behalf and applied to us.
So Christ is a better mediator because he's the mediator of a better covenant.
All right. So we've seen the covenant that he established. All right. Let's secondly see
the communion that he enables. So what do we see here? The covenant that we read about at the
start of the chapter then leads to the communion that we have later on in the chapter there in
verses nine to 11 and even through the rest of the chapter. So you have a relationship that is
established, but also this relationship that is experienced. So after the book is read and
the blood is applied, Moses, Aaron, Nadab, Elihu and 70 of the elders of Israel went further up
and further in to the presence of God. So what did they experience there in God's presence?
Verse 10 tells us it says, and they saw the God of Israel at the end of verse 11. It summarizes
what happened there. It says they beheld God and ate and drank. I don't know about you, but when I
read that, I've got so many questions. They did what? They beheld God? They ate and drank there
in his presence? You know, the Bible says no one, God says this, no one shall see me and live,
says it plainly. And here it says they beheld God twice, says that. Well, where it says no
one shall see me and live is actually in Exodus 33 verse 20. Before that, God tells Moses, you cannot
see my face. No one shall see me and live. And yet there is a revelation of God. He does then behold
God, which we'll look at later on. So we have to say this, that they experience here a true
sight of God's majesty, and yet it's still a partial and veiled sight of his majesty. So they
truly behold him even though it's partial and veiled. So instead of a description of like what God looks
like here and what it then says, it gives us a description of what is below God's feet, interestingly.
It says there was, as it were, a pavement of sapphire stone like the very heaven for clearness.
So they look and see a floor below the Lord that looks like a beautiful blue gemstone. It
looks like a clear blue sky. So to point out the obvious, the sky is normally something you see
when you are looking up. But for the Lord it is below him because he stands above all things in
heaven and on earth. So this is likely communicating something similar to what the Lord will go on to
say in Isaiah 66 and verse one, heaven is my throne and the earth is my footstool. So here
they are high up on this mountain, but the Lord is far higher still. Heaven is his throne, the earth
is his footstool. Interestingly, the prophet Ezekiel has a very similar vision of God in Ezekiel
chapter one. And when he saw the Lord in this way, he falls down before him in worship.
You see the Lord, here's what it's showing us here by them, the holding God is saying
he is highly exalted and he is worthy of worship, bowing down before him.
And yet this Lord who is high and lifted up desires to be with and to commune with people.
How could they deny that the Lord wanted to commune with people because they saw it with
their own eyes. They saw him, they beheld him. They didn't just see God, they ate and drank in
his presence. Another question I've got was what were they eating? You know sacrifices and meals
were often combined together in the Old Testament once again. We saw that in the Passover.
And you get this with the priestly sacrifices as well. So it could have been, they offered
these sacrifices and then food from the sacrifices that was offered was then brought up with them.
Don't know. But the thing that our attention is drawn to isn't what they are eating,
but what that is telling us, the fact that they were eating in the presence of God. This is pointing
to the intimacy of fellowship with God that they have been brought into. You see sharing food together
is an indication of friendship and fellowship. You see there's a difference between like being
part of a crowd, like observing someone at a distance and actually sitting around the table
enjoying a meal with that person. They're enjoying fellowship with God truly. The fact is we were all
created for communion, fellowship with God. You see this through the whole of Scripture.
I mean go back to the Garden of Eden, God there dwelling with man. This is why God is bringing
His people into this covenant with Himself for communion. You then look at Jesus, John 17.3.
He says this is eternal life that they may know you. It's about knowing the Lord, true communion
with Him. The near the end of Revelation and says this about the new creation. Behold the dwelling
place of God is with man. He will dwell with them and they will be His people and God Himself will
be with them as their God. And there are times when communion with the Lord, especially that kind
of on the last day and the new creation, where that's described as enjoying a meal. So Isaiah 25
is a wonderful passage. There you have a vision of the Lord on a mountain inviting people from
all nations to a feast that He will provide. He is the host that invites people from all of
the world to commune with Him in this joyful feast that He gives. There He swallows up
death. There He talks about beholding Him and rejoicing in His salvation. So if you know the
Lord, that's where all this is heading for that meal and His presence. And this is what they are
experiencing a taste of as He welcomes them to His table. But you know, when you read this,
somebody might say, well that's well and good if you're one of those elders that got to
actually go up into His presence. What about the ordinary people at the bottom of the mountain?
Sure, they're enjoying that communion. Everybody else is still way at a distance.
Make me think of something that happened a few years ago. Me and some other missionaries who
were part of an organization I was working for at the time were invited to come to Oxford. We
lived in England. So invited to Oxford to this conference about the life of C.S. Lewis,
his life and work. And we were going to go to where he lived and where he worked. And
there were some like top scholars from who were going to be there and they were going to be sharing
with us about him and his influence on their lives. And I thought, this would be amazing.
This sounds like a great opportunity. Don't want to pass it up. So I went along to it. I was the
only missionary who took him up on the offer to go for free. And so when I got there,
I imagine in Oxford, this is when I walked in the room where the first meeting was,
it was exactly as you would imagine, it was a banquet. So it was in this banquet hall
and you had this long table. It had all these beautiful candleabras and you know,
just kind of intricate details all around you in the architecture. And I arrived early. I thought,
this is amazing. There was one person who sat at the end of the table and it was a guy called
Walter Hooper who was C.S. Lewis, his last secretary who was still living at the time.
And so I walked over and I sat down next to Walter Hooper and I started to talk with him.
And then some other people started to arrive. But as soon as other people arrived,
somebody made a beeline to me and they came up to me and they said,
excuse me, can I speak to you for a second? They pulled me over and they said,
this banquet is for our paying guests only. And so I had to, about face, apologize and
I sheepishly walked out the door and made my way all the way to Burger King where I belonged.
I hadn't realized that these posh meals were not included in my free ticket.
As a credit to them, they did include meals and other things afterwards.
I imagine going there and not being invited in because you weren't a paying guest.
You wonder if that's, you look at these people at the bottom of the mountain thinking,
are they not invited in? The thought of close table fellowship with God sounds wonderful,
but you may think that is it really for me? When we look to Jesus, we see that the
answer is a resounding yes. The fact is, you are invited to table fellowship with God,
not because you can afford it, but because Jesus paid the price for you.
So the invitation is to all who will come, who will return from their sin, but their trust in Jesus.
We're invited this table fellowship because of what he has done for us.
So Hebrews 10 19 tells us that there's not this graduated access. No, we can enter into the
holy places, the place of communion with God by the blood of Jesus. The fact is, when we see
him in his outstretched arms on Mount Calvary, we see that his arms are open to welcome anyone who
will come to him. So how do we experience that communion through faith in Christ? It's something
we're going to experience one day, but let's let's let's push in deeply. How do we experience that
communion, that fellowship with God right now? Well, there's some patterns here. First of all,
we experience it when we behold Christ by faith in his word. The Lord's given us a book. And
as we hear the word of God in light of who Jesus is, we see more of who he is as we read 2nd
Corinthians 3 and 4. There we see that as we read the word of God, the spirit of God opens our
eyes that we might be hold the glory of God in the face of Jesus. You want to hold God as they
did there so we can behold his glory in the face of Jesus as the spirit of God opens our eyes
through the word. That's not just a one time thing when you first come to know Jesus, it's an ongoing
thing that we're invited to. We behold him there. We also behold him, or you enter communion with
him as we come to his table as we're going to in just a moment. The Lord invites us to
commune with him at his table. This is why we call it communion. The bread and the wine,
just to be clear, are not a continual sacrifice that is being made to atone for our sins,
but rather they are pointing to the once and for all sacrifice that Jesus made for our sins.
Yet as we as we eat the bread and we drink the wine, the Lord by his spirit is truly
present among us. So we're eating, remembering what he has done for us.
But also we know communion, fellowship with God in the welcome that we show one another,
in the fellowship of his people. I think, hang on, I thought we were talking about
communion with God, not with each other. But here's what the Apostle John says in 1 John 412.
He says, no one has ever seen God. That's that Exodus 33 passage. But then he says,
but then he says, but if we love one another, God abides in us and his love is perfected in us.
So what's he saying there? He's connecting that kind of beholding God, communion with him,
with the love that we experience in our fellowship, one with another. So God's love is made visible
in the love of his people. So you look at somewhere like Romans 15, 7, you see that God's
spirit works in us so that we might welcome one another as we have been welcomed by God in Christ.
And so as we welcome one another, enter fellowship with one another, check in with one another,
by the Lord's help, we are experiencing communion with the Lord because it's communion
empowered by the Lord. So fellowship is an integral part of our worship.
So how can sinful people draw near to a holy God? It's because Jesus died for our sins.
He's a mediator of a better covenant and the one who brings us into communion with God.
So how should we respond? Well, Hebrews 10 tells us exactly how we should respond.
Verse 22, let us draw near. He's opened up the way. Let us draw near unto him.
We're not like the people who had to stay far off. We're invited to draw near to the very throne room
of God as his children and find it to be a throne of grace where we are welcomed in Christ.
In Hebrews 10, 23, it says, let us draw near and let us hold fast to our confession.
Let's continue to confess our faith in Christ. Hold fast to what Scripture has told us about
him, what God has told us about him through his word. And then it says in verse 24,
and let us consider how to stir up one another in love and good works. It's calling us here to
faithfully and frequently gathered together that we might be formed in the communion of the saints
into a people who are a worshiping community who reflect the love of God and glorify him
together in our lives. So what I first to do now is to draw near to the Lord, first of all,
in prayer, and then we'll draw near to his table together. So spend the moment where you are
responding to the Lord in prayer, and then I'll pray and invite us to partake in the Lord's
supper.
Lord, we are
so grateful that you invite us to draw near to your throne of grace.
Lord, you are holy and we are sinful. But we thank you
for the death of Jesus. We thank you that through his blood we can draw near to you with confidence
that in Christ we are forgiven and cleansed and welcomed as your children.
And so Lord, as we come to your table now together, Lord, I pray that we would know your presence
and help. Lord, that you would open our eyes that we might behold you as we eat and drink
and rememberance of Jesus, body broken, and his blood shed for us. In his name we pray. Amen.
The Apostle Paul wrote this in 1 Corinthians 11. He said, For I received from the Lord what I also
delivered unto you, that on the night in which Jesus was betrayed, he took bread.
And when he had given thanks, he broke it and said, This is my body, which is broken for you.
Do this in remembrance of me. In the same manner, he took the cup after supper, saying,
This cup is the new covenant in my blood. Do this as often as you drink it in remembrance of me.
As often as you eat this bread and drink this per cup, drink this cup, you proclaim the Lord's death
until he comes. So as we just said, this is an opportunity for us to draw near to the Lord's
table together as his people. So if you have turned from your stand and put your faith in
Christ, if you can honestly say, I believe that Jesus died and rose again, you're invited
to come to the table. You'll see in the worship guide as well that we do connect it too with baptism,
because in our baptism, we are confessing that faith in Christ as well. So if you are believing Christ
and you've made that known publicly in that way, we're drawing near now together to the Lord's
table. And as we do so, let's do so looking to the Lord, remembering what he has done for us.
And so you're invited to draw near in that way. The way we practice that here is you'll take a
piece of the bread and you'll hear the words, the body of Christ broken for you. And you'll
then dip it into the wine. It's non-alcoholic wine. And you'll hear the words, the blood of Christ
shed for you. There's also cups here that are gluten free if you need to have gluten free
bread. So I'm going to invite Nick to come forward and he's going to help to serve that with me.
And then once the music begins, we're all invited to stand together as we have this time.